about graphical criteria for the
inequality constraints
indirect the basic graphs within
variables
hello everyone i am bata i am currently
a phd student at ict in science and i
work
so i would like to start with thanking
the organizers of this workshop because
as someone who's interested in both
quantum foundations and statistical
cousin models i must say that i really
enjoyed the past few days so thank you
for giving me the opportunity to be here
so today i will talk about some work
that i did while i was in the premature
institute for physical physics uh as you
can see it's a joint work with
no amping feinstein who was actually
giving a talk yesterday and i'm sure you
will see some similarities between what
he was talking about and like some of
the results that i will show today uh
it's also a joint work with ellie and
elia who are here with us today
and with robs petkins who is with us
online okay so since i know that we have
a lot of quantum people here as well i
want to start with some important
definitions just to make sure that
everyone is on the same page
okay so i will be talking about directed
exactly graphs and in blacks we have
three types of structures that occur so
we have forks colliders and you have
chains and i would like to introduce an
idea of a path being either closed or
open
depending on the conditioning set
so we will say that forks and chains are
open
uh if we do not condition on z where you
can see that that is like
this node in a fork or this one in the
chain
and we will say that they are closed
otherwise in a case of colliders we'll
say that they are open if we do
condition onset or is the sentence and
they're close otherwise so where are we
talking about a path being open
or closed what we do is we consider all
contiguous triples along that path and
we want to see whether there are open
and closed under the conditioning set
and this definition now allows me to
introduce d separation
so
let a b and c be sets of variables in a
dac we say that a
and b are d separated by c
if all paths between a and b are closed
after conditioning on c okay and i will
denote it as here so what is the
intuition behind this this definition
something that we already heard about
during this conference is that every
time we have a d separation relation in
a dac it implies a conditional
independence constrained in the
data distribution compatible with the
stack so if a and b are d separated by c
in the dac then a and b are
conditionally independent given c okay
in the related
distribution okay one more definition
that i want to introduce is e-separation
so when i'm saying that a node can be
deleted from a graph i mean removing the
node and all its in-going and outgoing
edges and now we can say that abn
if we have variables a b
c and d in the dac a and b are e
separated by c after donation of d
if a and b are d separated by c after
deletion of every variable in d okay so
i'll denote it as here
and now what is the intuition behind
this definition so you see that it's
related to the separation but it's
slightly different because now i
introduce this idea of removing a node
from a graph right so in this case
i'll say that the variable the set of
variables d that we are removing are
bottlenecks between a and b conditional
on c because if you focus on this
definition you will see that d must be
any set of variables such that it
contains at least one node from every
path that is open between a and b after
we condition on c okay so then when we
remove d from the graph
uh this close will be now closed and we
will have the the related d separation
relation okay so in other words we can
say that
uh when d is a bottleneck
what i mean is that all informa
information shared between a and b
conditional on c must flow freely okay
great
so
now that you have the definitions we can
talk a little bit more about equality
constraints implied by dax so this is
the idea that we are already familiar
with when we have a dag we can read off
some information from it and we know
that it will imply some constraints on a
probability distribution that is
compatible with this dac
so one that we already heard about even
at the previous presentation is just the
mark of condition so if we have a dark t
with some variables v
they must decompose as follows right so
if we have a duck if we have some data
we have some probability distribution
and all the variables in our dac are
observed variables we can actually test
you know this condition and see if the
probability distribution is compatible
with a lag
another one that i already mentioned is
the one connected to this separation so
if we are given a dag and we can you
know read of the d separation relations
from it we know that we should expect
the corresponding uh conditional
independence relations in the
distribution that corresponds to the
stack okay
conditional independence relations are
already also equality constraints
and moreover
um we have this feature that if we want
to test them we need the variables in
the set z
c sorry in the conditioning set to be
observed okay because what happens if
you have some unobserved variables in a
dac
if you have unobserved variables here we
won't be able to test the the
corresponding conditional independence
constraints right
and this is something that i want to
focus on today i want to ask how to
study causal models with unobserved
variables
and there are some approaches to this
problem
one is called quantifier elimination
algorithm i don't really want to go into
detail here but basically what we can do
is that if we have a lag with some set
of variables uh we can
take all the constraints that we have on
the observed and unobserved variables
run the quantifier elimination algorithm
and try to eliminate the unobserved
variables from our constraints because
at the end of the day even if you have a
dog with you know unobserved variables
what we want is construct a constraint
or a set of constraints on the observed
data distribution right so we want to
eliminate the unobserved variables from
our constraints
and we can do it in principle with
quantifier elimination algorithm and
we'll get some uh inequality constraints
from it and the problem here is that
it's a numerically and not always
tractable so for example if you have a
dac of like six or seven variables
including the the hidden ones uh it
becomes challenging to get you know the
set of
inequality constraints
okay
it was also shown to by evans that every
time we have an e-separation relation
like this there will be a constraint on
the observed data distribution okay so
whenever we have this operation we have
an equality constraint whenever we have
e-separation
we also have some constraint but this
result was not really constructive in a
way that it didn't show how to you know
get the specific constraint so when we
have this operation we know that we have
conditional independence and now the
question is when we have e separation
what is the constraint that we can get
on the
data distribution from this e-separation
relation
and this is the question that i will
answer today but before i go to the
main you know like formal theorem i just
want to present you one example that i
think gives a very nice like intuitive
way of understanding the type of
constraints that i'll be talking about
today
okay so let's consider this example
let's say that we have amy bob and cathy
and amy want to send some information to
cathy but she can only do it through bob
now if bob only ever sends the same one
message to katie there is no way that
katy will learn something about amy's
not right
so how do we quantify this capacity of
bob being able to send some information
from amy to cathy we can do it with
entropy so in this case when bob only
sends the same node we say that both
bob's nodes have zero entropy where the
entropy of a random variable is defined
like this and it's minimized by a point
distribution so this is what's happening
here
okay so
what happens if the increasing the
entropy of bob's nose increases now
there is some potential for katie to
learn something about amy's note right
but there are no guarantees bob just can
be sending cut here anything so already
from here you get the flavor that we
won't have an equality constraint but
we'll have an inequality constraint
because the fact that bob's note the
entropy of bob's node uh increased
doesn't really mean that cat will
actually you know learn something about
amy's note okay because you still don't
know what is the information that he's
sending
so we can quite quantify
this example using mutual entropy which
is defined uh like this and here we
would say that the information shared
between amy and cathy is bounded from
above by entropy of both
okay so we have this this intuition here
okay so
i just wanted to show you this example
of course it's a very simple one and
here we can say that bob is a bottleneck
okay because all the information coming
from
amy to cathy must go through bob and we
see that the entropy of the bottleneck
is somehow connected to the mutual
information between you know the nodes
and our graph
between which one to pass the
information okay so formally and i will
not show the formal proof here but if
anyone is interested in it just let me
know uh oh sorry
we will have this theorem okay so we'll
be talking about discrete variables and
let's say that you have this
e-separation relation in lag so you
observe that a and b are e-separated
um a condition on c upon
the deletion of d
and in addition none no element of c is
a descendant of any indeed
then we have the following constraints
okay so this is exactly what we wanted
to do we are we are given we observe an
e-separation relation and from it
we have a way of constraining of putting
together you know constraints
uh
on the variables of interest
if in addition no element of a is a
descendant of any of d then we can get
stronger constraints
which are given here so as you can see
the difference here is that
here we are also conditioning on d so we
are also conditioning on the bottleneck
while here d goes here so we have the
mutual information between a and b and d
okay so let me illustrate how this
theorem works uh in an example and at
the same time i will answer a question
that might be in your head right now and
is that i was talking about quantifier
elimination technique previously right
so
you might ask if we have this theorem
now that obviously seems easier right we
just have a dag we read the separation
narration and from it we have an
inequality constraint how does it relate
to results that we can get
when we just use quantifier elimination
okay so let's start with this example
say that we have the following dac so as
you can see we have like two confinders
here and this is just a chain
so if you want to apply the theorem the
first thing that we need to do is to
identify the bottlenecks or identify the
separation relations so for example
let's say that we're interested
in mutual information between a and that
then of course all information must pass
through x and y and this can be also
formalized by you know e-separate and
e-separation statement and from this we
will get the defining inequality
constraints
okay so
uh you can see that i use the the
stronger version of the theorem here the
conditioning set is just an empty set
here and we have the mutual information
between a and y and that in this case
and here we're talking in the second
case you're talking about mutual
information between a and y
a and z sorry
okay so we have these two inequality
constraints and it turns out that in
this particular example we recall or
shannon type and drop it inequality
constraints implied by the graph so
these are the same constraints that you
will get you know just using quantifier
elimination technique which is great
because obviously this way is like a way
faster way of getting the constraints on
the other hand we can also look at a
different example so now you see that
instead of having an edge here we have
this edge and we still have two
compounders
we can identify what are the separation
relations here relations here and we
will observe these two inequality
constraints now if you were to run a
quantifier elimination algorithm you'll
get this constraint as well so you can
see that the first one that we get here
can be strengthened to this form so the
difference here is that here we have the
entropy of of x and here we are
additionally condition uh isn't the
entropy of x condition on y so this is a
stronger constraint than this one okay
so we see that this is not always the
case that we'll get all inequality
constraints using this technique
but it's still very useful especially if
we have ducts with multiple variables
and it would be hard to run the
quantifier elimination in the first
place
okay
so we do have some related results in
the
in the paper and i don't want to go like
too much into details when it comes to
them and like give too many examples
because we also don't have that much
time but i i will mention them so just
if you have any questions we can discuss
it during the questions session or maybe
later so first related result is that it
is possible to relate our inequality
constraints to equality constraints for
example to the one related to the
separation the conditional independence
ones but also to vermont verma
constraints
and it is done through this proposition
that if a is d separated from b by the
set c d then a is also e separated from
b by c upon deleting d so every time we
have a d separation relation we'll also
have this corresponding e separation
relation
but this doesn't work the other way
around
okay
okay so now let me talk about some
applications of this result
the first one is about causal discovery
so let's say that we observe the data
distribution okay so we have a
distribution over the observed variables
here so all the all the y's
and we know our causal hypothesis that
the observed data distribution is
described by one of these ducts and
they're very similar except that this
one contains a directed edge from y1 to
i4 okay so the question that we're
asking here is we have a data
distribution
we we know that this structure holds and
in addition we want to know whether
there is a direct causal effect from y1
to y4 okay
so if we have a probability distribution
over the observed variables the first
thing that we do is we test the equality
constraints right but in this case it
turns out that the two ducks
share the conditional independence
constraints so thus by using the
equality constraints it's impossible to
distinguish between the two
but what you can do we can use our
inequality constraints so we can write
down the separation relations that hold
in the graph
and yeah let me go from the bottom here
you see that this one is shared between
the two so not focus on it but for
example let's look at this one
so we have that y1 and y2 so these two
are e separated from pi 4
if we take if we remove this node from a
graph
right makes sense but now if you go to
this example even if we remove this node
from a graph we still have this edge
here so this is separation relation
would not longer no longer hold so we
have it here but it does not hold for
this deck
and now we have one more separation
relation uh and the thing is that this
one is stronger than this one okay so
you can see that they're similar but in
here we have y4 and here we only have y3
and it's also because of this edge that
this constraint is stronger than this
one
so i didn't write down the resultant
inequality constraints here but you know
for every separation relation we are
able to use the theorem to write the
inequality constraints
and then you can use this inequality
constraints to
reason about because of structure
great
another example that i have here
concerns latent variables so one more
related results that we had is that
remember i said when we have hidden
variables in the conditioning set we
cannot really test
the equality constraints right but what
we showed is that if you have some
additional information about the hidden
variable for example you know it's
cardinality or maybe you know it's
entropy then it's still possible to get
inequality constraints on the observed
variables that somehow use this
information that you have about the
latent variable
so let's say that we have the following
situation we observe this data
distribution
and our task is to decide between these
two causal structures so we do know that
there's a hidden common cause you know
but what we don't know and we want to
find out whether there also exists a
direct causal influence
from x on y
and let's assume let's say that we can
make the following assumption that the
cardinality of the hidden common cause
is equal to free and this is very often
i feel a valid assumption because even
though we cannot always you know observe
the confounder sometimes you can
identify what it is and then we know
also what what is the the cardinality
right
okay so we had the following proposition
in the paper that if a and b are d
separated by c and u where here
e u is the set of unobserved variables
then the following inequality holds okay
so you can see that on this side we only
have the observed variables and on this
side we have you the unabsorbed variable
but it's only the cardinality of you
that appears in the inequality okay so
for this specific
example
here we have free
again the conditioning set here is just
an empty set so we can compute
this expression and we will get
something that's slightly larger than
free okay
so uh
looking at this again here you d
separates x and y but here
it is not the case right so we if we
observe this probability distribution we
observe that this inequality is violated
and we can conclude that you know it's
impossible to explain in a model where
u d separates x and y so it's impossible
to explain in this model therefore we
have a direct causal influence from x to
i
now i think that this proposition is
very interesting because you can also
kind of use it the other way around if
you do not know anything about the
cardinality of the common cause but you
want to find out something about the
cardinality of the common cause so let's
say that we're still observing the same
data but now we are convinced that there
is you know no direct ozone influence
of x and y so this is just our causal
structure and what you want to do is we
want to bond the cardinality of the
hidden variable
then we can use the same proposition
again and what we now see is that this
cardinality uh in order you know so this
graph explains this observed data must
be at least equal to four
okay
um
one more one more application that we
find for for our
uh for our theorem
regards quantifying causal influence so
throughout the past two days we heard a
little bit about the average causal
effect and this is a very standard way
of a very you know traditional approach
for quantifying causal effect so it's
defined like this
and usually here we talk about some
treatment and some outcome and we
usually talk about binary treatment so
here x is the treatment it can take
these two values okay and this is how we
define the
the average causal effect and of course
you know this definition shown to be
useful in in multiple cases but there
are also some problems that can occur
when you use it for example you could
find a very specific scenario in which
you know every treatment will affect the
outcome but when you actually compute
the average causal effect it will be
equal to zero so you know the
the outcomes or like these terms will
somehow cancel out so you'll have the
average causal effect
of zero although there actually exists a
causal effect
of the treatment on the outcome so this
is one thing and another thing is that
you see it's defined for a binary
treatment right so we could somehow
extend it to the case where
x has higher cardinality than two
um but like originally the intuitive way
of understanding the average causal
effect is exactly this one for for
binary treatment so our response to this
was that
well we can use our theorem to help uh
in our intuition that we develop v
separation to define a new way of
quantifying the influence that maybe can
be used alongside the average causal
effect to give us some additional
information about the strength of a
causal arrow
okay we called it a minimal mediary
entropy mme and it works as follows
let's say that we are interested in the
strength or this arrow so it's a
directed causal effect
of x on y okay and we know that we have
this that now
it goes as follows what we need to do
is to introduce
two additional latent variables w and u
such that the w mediates the whole
causal effect along this path okay so
instead of having this one edge here now
we have the w media it's the causal
effect of x on y
and of course we can always allow for
this hidden common cause for for w and y
because if we want to change the
structure overall
okay so now that we have this new bag
the the question that we can ask uh is
you know
what is the entropy of w such that we
can recover this situation here and now
this definition very
much you know reflects the the fact
about
like maybe not bottlenecks but
the idea of conveying information along
the path and how the entropy of
a variable along the path is connected
to how much information we can actually
transfer
so we define the
minimum immediate entropy to be the
smallest entropy of w
where w is the
variable that we inserted
over all structural equation models
reproducing the observed data
distribution
over the modified dac so for this one in
which w has finite cardinality
okay and i won't really give you any
examples here and just from looking at
the definition you could ask okay how do
i
you know optimize over all structural
equation models but we can actually show
that in some cases our theorem would be
useful to just give a bound on
on the entropy of w okay so in
particular if we observe this is e
separation relation we're here deleting
w uh w and sunset d so you can see that
w here would be just like you know a
part of of the whole bottleneck the
setup that we call the bottleneck
then we'll be able to to put a bound on
the on mme from x to y
uh that depends on the
you know mutual information
and the entropy
so there is one bound there are also
some trivial bonds that we can put
and of course although it would be hard
to optimize over all structural
equations we can look into like some
specific examples and try to you know
tighten the bounds that we already have
okay so now i want to move to a
different result that also regards
equality constraints but from this part
of the presentation i think the most
important take-home message is that
e-separation relations imply entropic
inequality constraints okay so every
time we have an e-separation relation
we can just give the
you know the corresponding entropic
inequality constraint
that mass that constrains the
probability distribution
okay
so now i i will be still talking about
inequality constraints but i want to
focus on this particular case of
restricted cardinality so where you have
an unobserved variable but we know its
cardinality
and in order to present one more result
i need to introduce one more definition
and is that if p is a non-negative
matrix uh the non-negative rank of p
isn't the smallest number r such that p
can be decomposed like this okay so we
have this non-negative matrix and we are
looking for this kind of decomposition
where this is one of this would be a row
vector one is a column vector but you
can see that the number of terms in the
decomposition
is r and what we want to do is we want
to minimize this r okay and this is what
people call a non-negative rank
now why is it interesting because it can
be interpreted as a measure of
dependence
so if you have if
it's a trivial observation that you can
represent the probability distribution
as a non-negative matrix right and now
if it's a probability distribution over
x and y and x and y are independent then
of course you'll have this factorization
and in this case the non-negative rank
of this matrix here is equal to 1.
but now as the correlation between x and
y
increases so that's the non-negative
rank for the distribution okay so it can
be treated as this measure of dependence
and now maybe it sounds familiar
familiar to you with respect to
something else that we can treat as a
measure of dependence and it has to do
with
conditional independence
okay so we if we have x and y and there
are conditionally independent given sum
that then you can write down the
following equation now
okay if x and y are actually independent
and we do not need you know z to make
them conditionally independent
uh r is just equal to one right and
we'll just have this term here
and again the more correlation we have
between x and y the higher must be the
cardinality of that in order to you know
explain this conditional independence so
i hope you can see this this
correspondence here that here
you know as the non-negative rank
increases x and y can have stronger
correlations and here is the same but
with the cardinality of that
and it can actually be shown that these
two numbers so the non-negative rank and
this cardinality of that correspond to
each other
the way i want to show you the results
is i want to still you know talk about
the graphical criteria so again we can
connect conditional independence to this
operation and you can make through
through this slide the connection
between this separation and non-negative
rank and it goes as follows
so the non-negative rank
of the matrix
that describes the probability
distribution over variables x and y
constitutes a lower band for the
cardinality of a variable z that d
separates x and y
okay so we have this inequality
constraint that again can be used if uh
you know if you have unobserved
variables so in here x and y can be
observed must be observed
and that could be an unobserved variable
it's a d separating set okay so it's
something that we condition on but since
we know its cardinality we can use this
inequality constraint to reason about
the causal structure
okay so
uh we could use it uh for causal
discovery so there is this one example
that i showed you know before with
relation to this other inequality
constraint where we want to you know see
whether there is a direct causal
influence from x to y so i don't want to
go for this example again but i hope you
can see that the flavor of this
inequality is very similar to the flavor
you know with the inequality with
again the cardinality of the hidden
variable so i could just like go over
the same example and use this
cardinality instead
and and see uh you know how i can reason
about because of structures so let me
not do that and let me focus on a
different example that i also find very
interesting and it's about distribution
generation so distribution generation is
a problem that's studied in
communication theory and goes as follows
suppose that we have two parties alice
and bob and they're responsible for
gener generating random variables so
alice generates x bob generates y and
they want to generate it in such a way
that they have a pre-specified joint
probability distribution
okay
so there are different ways in which
they can generate it and now two
different questions that people ask
oh sorry but we have a bird here
okay
that's nice okay
so
sorry
two questions that people ask in this
situation goes as follows so the first
one is how much information must be
communicated to generate this
probability distribution and here i'm
talking about one-way communication so
for example how am i like how many bits
must alice sends to bob for them to be
able to generate this pre-specified
probability distribution
and in the literature this this number
is referred to as random when it's
communication complexity and this is a
pretty well studied problem
and this is the result so this is the
number of bits that they need to
communicate to generate this probability
distribution
now a different question that you can
ask is how much information must be
shared between alice and bob for them to
generate this probability distribution
again a pretty well-studied problem
is referred to as randomized correlation
complexity and is given by the same
number actually and now
i think the nice feature of
of this problem is that if you look at
the literature it's a well studied
problem but people usually consider
these two questions
as two very different questions that are
not connected to each other at all and
the way that they get these results is
maybe not very complicated but it
requires a bunch of algebraic
manipulations while with the result that
i show you of the on the previous slide
you can actually see a very close
connection between these two questions
and you can just answer the question
straight away
so what you need to do is you just need
to take a causal approach okay
so what this question is really asking
is that we have
alice we have bob and now we have some
mediator and we want to know what is the
cardinality like the minimum cardinality
of this mediator such that you know x
and y can have some pre-specified
probability distribution
and now if you look at this question
what we really have is just a common
cause and the question that we are
asking is what is the cardinality of
this common cause you know such that x
and y we have this pre-specified
probability distribution
and in both of these graphs of course
that d separates x and y okay so it
turns out that this is actually uh you
know these two questions are very much
related to each other and we can use the
corollary to to get the answer by the
way
so
the result was that uh
the cardinality of that must be bounded
by the non-negative rank and you know we
just put the algorithm here for it to
correspond to how the question was
originally asked so i think that this
causal approach gives you a very nice
perspective on this problem and shows
that it really can be simplified
uh when we look at it this way
okay and now one more connection that we
can do with this problem
is to ask about the quantum
generalization okay so in the previous
slide we had access to classical
information so that was a classical
variable but now we can ask you know we
still have the same task and you're
asking what is the minimal dimension of
a quantum state okay that alice and bob
you know either communicate so they have
a quantum channel and like the question
is what is the dimension of the quantum
stage sent from alice to bob if they
want to generate this probability
distribution or what is the minimal
dimension of the quantum state that they
share
you know and somehow use this
information from this quantum state to
generate to
generate this probability distribution
and
i just want to make it clear that this
is a problem that was also studied in
the literature and we didn't contribute
to the quantum generalization but i
still want to point it out here because
i think it's a very interesting
connection to our result in the in the
classical case
okay so to answer this question i need
to introduce one last definition and
this is a positive semi-definite rank of
a negative matrix it's
again what we are interested in doing is
just we have some matrix and we want to
make some particular decomposition okay
and the psd rank is just basically
minimizing r where r corresponds to the
dimension of this matrices i don't think
it has you know as nice of a
interpretation as a non-negative rank
but we just need it as a definition here
because what people showed is that the
dimension so d here states for this
dimension of the quantum state
is bounded by the psd rank of this
probability distribution so you can see
that the resemblance that in our results
here on this side we had a cardinality
of a classical variable now we have a
dimension of the quantum state and in
our results we had a non-negative rank
here but now we have a psd rank and
something that's a nice feature but not
very surprising is that
in principle psd rank can be smaller
than the non-negative rank so if you
want to generate a probability
distribution uh
you know the dimension of the quantum
stage that we need in order to do it can
be in principle lower and it can be you
know a very big difference a significant
difference than the cardinality of a
classical variable that we would need in
order to generate this probability
distribution so i think that this is
just a very nice connection between the
two problems and
of course the classical case is
definitely you know well studied because
we had this whole connection to this
operation by hill
you know in the quantum case you were
just talking about shining a quantum
state or communicating a quantum state
so we don't have you know a very nice
result that would we could apply to any
kind of quantum
causal structure that we could use but
still i think this connection was
important to point out
and yeah that's all i wanted to say
today so thank you for your attention
great so thank you for the very nice
talk and there are several questions
back there so i'll start at the back
this time
thank you very nice talk uh just one
question you had a result uh early on
where you said e-separation the
inequalities were gave you everything
and i just could you say a couple of
words about how how the proof for that
works
oh so it's just if you were to run the
quantifier elimination technique
it's one of the
one of the dags that were studied in the
paper when they like
derived the like full set of
inequalities and just by comparison you
can say you can see that you get the
same with your separation so
yeah thanks thanks for the very nice
talk i was wondering if you could say a
bit about
related to the part where you discuss
causal discovery what kind of
faithfulness type assumption might be
relevant in that setting so
if for example when you were comparing
a and b were confounded by you versus
the one where they were confounded and
there's also an edge so is there some
sort of underlying assumption that you
have thought about that would say that
that edge is like real that it really
that the con the inequality like binds
in some sense
so we didn't really consider that but of
course like you need to imply
the faithfulness principle because like
of course it would be possible that you
have some like fine tuning right and
this is why we do not observed yet
but i cannot really say anything more
about like the particular
uh are other inequalities captured by
and
entropic inequality are their inquiries
that are not in the form of uh
controversial inequalities
but you okay so you're not asking about
the that's implied by the in separation
but in principle
right there might be inequalities that
the model might imply uh some inequality
but it's not in the form of entropy is
that possible yes of course
but on the other hand it's also possible
like for example we have body
inequalities right that are not captured
in terms of entropies but on the other
hand i believe that you can write down a
entropic version of bell inequalities so
like there is some correspondence but
the answer to your question is yes
do you know what is like the gap or what
type of
inequalities are captured by entropic
type like what what's missing
why it's missing
that's an interesting question uh
so one thing that i can say that you
know for sure from the example that we
have here entropies are good for
capturing this idea of a bottleneck so
this is why they correspond to these
separation relations but also when you
use quantifier elimination technique you
are looking for this
uh
inequalities in the channel con right so
you also get entropic inequalities i'm
sorry i'm looking at
here but i think he might get a better
sense of that as well
yeah so like there's definitely some
intuition behind it
but not like a uh full well-defined
intuition that would tell you why this
like entrepreneurial quality constraints
and the other inequality constraints are
not in terms of measures
okay i have a question uh
it's a in your example
you have this 2 to the power 1.549
could you just
say a little bit how
uh you get that number i want to
understand this more concretely okay
yes of course
okay let me just find the example
okay so we're talking about this one
right
okay so is your question how do we get
this result or just how do we compute
okay so it's just we just need to
compute the mutual information and since
we are giving the observed data mutual
information is just uh
you know given in terms of entropies of
x and y and the entropy of x and y which
are well defined so we can just like
compute the entropies and then plug it
into the definition and
in that table so
say for the first 1.002 what does it
mean
yeah sorry so this is just like observed
data as such that these are the
probability distributions so you can see
that like if you sum over the right ones
but it's just we are assuming that x has
cardinality 4 so it can take
these four values and the same for y
and for example that the probability
distribution
of getting this result in this result is
is equal to this
okay thank
you okay i think we have time for one
more question and then it's time for the
break but piata is here so we can
ask
some questions
so just to follow up on that last
question so so you just
the assumption is that this is the
distribution and it's known perfectly
we're not taking this so i wondered if
you thought about
taking into account sampling variability
when you're using entropy as uh
naturally so to be honest when you came
up with this example we wanted a
particular data
that would
violate the scene and quality so this is
like very much fine-tuned to violate
just this inequality and i guess your
question is if you don't know this
exactly
what is like of course we wouldn't be
able to estimate it
well then i guess it depends like for
example
here this number is very close to this
one right so if we won't be a like if we
didn't know this exactly then it is
possible that we wouldn't be able to
decide between these two structures but
i think if we are using this proposition
the other way around and we are just
interested in maybe the order of
magnitude was like more or less what you
is
we could still
kind of get a sense of the cardinality
of the hidden variable even if we didn't
know the distribution exactly
so i think let's thank me out there
again and then move to the break